Neil deGrasse Tyson I asked you to take
the dog out for a walk when I left the
house four hours ago now come back and
this little [__] Sputnik is
done pissed on my drapes now I've got to
get rid of those things and get new ones
Neil it doesn't make any sense you're an
astrophysicist how can you not keep
track of little details like this
well
actually
it's the little details that cannot be
kept track of by definition
in 1927 a German University lecturer
named Warner Heisenberg came to a
seemingly paradoxical conclusion
that the more we know about the position
of a particle in physical space the less
we know about its momentum and vice
versa